احتفالا بالمئويه الثانيه على انشائه في
عام
1824 يقدم المتحف المصري في مدينه تورينو
الايطاليه شكلا ومصارا جديدين ضمن مشروع
يعبر عن تراث المدينه ومعالمها السياحيه
وسيكون المسار الجديد للمتحف اكثر سهوله
مع انشاء ساحه تحم تحمل اسم الساحه
المصريه وستكون مفتوحه مجانا للمواطنين
وسائحين ومنذ ردهه المتحف من خلال مستوى
عين سيكوننا الممكن للوصول بحريه وبغض
النظر عن مسارحه الى المعبد الذي تبرعت به
مصر لايطاليا في عام 1970 تقديرا لمساهمه
ايطاليا في انقاذ معابد النوبه بعد بناء
سد اسوان يذكر ان عدد زوار المتحف الذي
اكبر مجموعه من التحف المصريه والتي
يبلغ عددها 30,000 قطعه قد زاد بنسبه خمسه
في المئه عام 2002 2020 مقارنه طبعا
بمستويات ما قبل الوفاء
[موسيقى]